If it were the Knight of the Waves, he wouldn't be able to move an inch
and would be knocked down.If he wasn't able to do that, he wouldn't be able to
compete.Always maintaining his own distance even as he sends out his
spear.He's amazing.This guy closes the distance every time he sends out his spear.
No, it's a good
attack.As
expected of me, I was impressed by their tenacity to stand up immediately after receiving that blow.And
above all, they have
n't lost their fighting spirit at all.It's
amazing.Why are
they trying to reach the Highlanders when they have this much power?  They're trying to steal it away. Are they just going to
overlook it or lend a helping hand?
At least the
spirit-sama seems to be a kind person, and the
townspeople seem to
love it too.  Are you not
aware of the strangeness in the town? Is it that the flow of mana is unnatural?
What's going on? If you've
noticed, you should look into it yourself and
realize the foolishness of what you're doing. I
can't help but feel that way.  But
unfortunately, I don't have any cause or ambition, so I
ate too much and ran out of Login, so I
cooperated with you to earn money.
Thanks to you, I can fight with you, so I am
grateful for my greed.
What is the point of power without justice?  It's
just fun for me, you
idiot. I
won't
allow someone like you to have power. It's something I've often avoided.
This is an attack that transcends space and distance. This is
her hidden seriousness.
Interesting.  I've been
waiting.
Now, what should I do? I
read the other side's movements, not only with spears, but also with kicks.
[Music]
Well, it was a good fight. It
was more fun than I imagined.